hallo deutschland ganz herzlich
willkommen bei uns in unserem corona
kompakt geht es heute um die masken
pflicht die ab montag für alle gilt wir
klären wie es für die schüler in corona
zeiten weiter geht und sie bekommen
antworten auf ihre fragen zur masken
pflicht immer wieder kommt auch die
frage auf welche maske schützt
eigentlich wie fußball in leeren stadien
was eigentlich undenkbar ist wird in
zeiten von corona eine echte option die
deutsche fußball liga gmbh ist
jedenfalls bereit für solche
geisterspiele
auch wenn es schwerfällt spiele ohne
zuschauer werden anders aussehen sie
werden sich anders anfühlen sie wären
auch sie werden sich auch anders anhören
und ich möchte die hier auch nicht
schöner darstellen als sie sind für den
moment sind sie aber nun mal die einzige
möglichkeit die bundesliga und zweite
bundesliga wie wir sie kennen am leben
zu erhalten
für viele profi-clubs stellt sich die
existenzfrage
tausende arbeitsplätze stehen auf dem
spiel die dfl kann jedoch ihr schicksal
nicht selbst bestimmen
für uns bleibt einzigen allein
entscheidend was die politisch
verantwortlichen beschließen und deshalb
liegt es auch nicht an uns einen
starttermin der bundesliga festzulegen
die frage wie und wann ein neustart
möglich ist stellt sich in allen
gesellschaftlichen bereichen beim robert
koch institut verweist man auf die
gefahren eines zu frühen neustart
wenn es wieder mehr enge kontakte
zwischen den menschen geben wird so wie
vorher
dann wird es auch mehr ansteckungen
geben nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind heute stand 16 uhr 30
153 1393 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt 100 6800 menschen gelten als
genesen abstand halten diese wohl
effektivste maßnahme gegen das corona
virus fällt manchmal schwer
gerade bei sommerlichem wetter wie hier
am hamburger elbstrand
man ist ja selber auch ausgegangen hat
halt gedacht dass mehr platz da ist im
endeffekt es fällt kein platz da so
dinge über die man sich dann halt erst
gedanken macht wenn es ein bisschen
länger wird wahrscheinlich und ich
glaube dass nach einer gewissen zeit
dass auch einfach wirklich sehr
schwierig wird auch gerade mit kindern
irgendwie drin zu bleiben das wetter ist
schön und da muss man einfach glaube ich
zwischendurch mal raus zwar gilt ab
montag im freien keine masken pflicht
aber fast alle bundesländer machen das
tragen von mund nasenschutz in
geschäften und öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln zur pflicht das
robert-koch-institut begrüßt heute
nochmals dem beschluss wir haben uns
jetzt entschlossen wie das tragen von
masken in der öffentlichkeit als
zusätzliche maßnahme zu empfehlen weil
wir eben wissen und dafür gibt es auch
neuere daten auch daten mit dem koma
virus dass der mund nasen schutz dieser
medizinische mund nasenschutz durchaus
eine gewisse verminderung der virus
ausscheidung bewirken kann
die verschiedenen masken typen haben
natürlich unterschiedliche
schutzfaktoren ffp masken ohne ventil
schützen träger und umfeld eine ffp
masken mit ventil schützt nur den träger
da aus dem ventil die atemluft normal
entweichen kann
einfache chirurgische masken schützen
den träger wenig dafür dass umfeld all
dies masken werden von medizin personal
gebraucht
wer einen selbst genähten mundschutz
oder ein schal um mund und nase trägt
schützt seine umwelt hat aber selbst
wenig eigenschutz sondern dies ist eine
altruistische maßnahme die in erster
linie dazu dient das versprühen von
kleinen tropfen die entstehen können
durch diese barriere so zu behindern
dass eben diese tropfen nicht so weit
fliegen um dann andere infektionen bei
anderen menschen setzen zu können
genau das zeigt dieser strömungs film
die tröpfchen werden mit mundschutz
nicht so weit verbreitet wichtig ist er
musst richtig sitzen eine maske tragen
sie sinnvoll wenn sie sie zum einen beim
aussetzen darauf achten dass sie den
nasenrücken über dem nasenrücken geführt
ist wirklich die nase bedeckt den mund
bedeckt und unters kinn gezogen ist auch
das richtige ausziehen ist wichtig die
maske an den bändern abziehen und nach
dem absetzen händewaschen
am mittwoch wird schleswig holstein als
letztes bundesland das tragen von mund
nasen schutz vorschreiben
ab dann gilt die pflicht deutschlandweit
ob medizinische maske oder selbst genäht
wer keine trägt muss in einigen
bundesländern sogar mit bußgeldern
rechnen
ab montag gilt bundesweit die massen
pflicht alle die mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln fahren oder einkaufen
gehen müssen eine maske tragen dazu
haben sie viele fragen und einige davon
klären wir jetzt mit zdf rechtsexperte
der attacke hallo sarah wir haben eine
frage bekommt von wilfried graf er
schreibt ich beziehe sozialleistungen
soll mich mit schutzmasken ausrüsten
inwieweit wo es die sozialbehörde oder
das jobcenter mir diese masken zahlen
aktuell ist das meines wissens nicht
vorgesehen man muss aber auch sagen eine
maske ist jetzt kein gegenstand der
einen bestimmten standard erfüllen muss
sondern man soll mund und nase bedeckt
haben das heißt man kann sich auch ein
t-shirt das man hat neben und umbinden
oder es gibt zum beispiel bayern hat ein
video gemacht jemand aus dem servierte
mit gummibändern sich die maske basteln
kann das heißt diese pflicht ist nicht
unbedingt etwas was viel kosten muss
sondern man muss nur dafür sorgen dass
man mund und nase am ende bedeckt hat
das kann man aber auch mit den
gegenständen die man sowieso zu hause
hat erfüllen ohne da viel geld
investieren zu müssen
holger kruse fragt was soll die masken
pflicht wenn es keine masken gibt ich
war gestern in sechs apotheken ohne
erfolg also kann ich ab montag keinen
ruß und supermarkt mehr betreten und
werde verhungern
niemand muss verhungern es gibt auch in
den meisten bundesländern eine gewisse
übergangsfrist also nicht jeder muss
sofort mitgetragen aber auch hier gilt
es
wäschereien also jeder bietet jetzt
selbst genähte masken an
es reicht ja auch ein schal wenn es
jetzt nicht ein gehäkeltes wo natürlich
irgendwie viel luft im stoff ist aber
ansonsten reicht das wirklich wenn man
die gegenstände die man sowieso zu hause
hat mit mit einfachen mitteln zu masken
umwandelt es gibt da kein standard ist
nicht vorgeschrieben wie eine maske
aussehen muss sondern nur das mund nase
sinnvoll bedeckt sind
das heißt man kann auch wenn man jetzt
noch eine apotheke keine maske bekommen
hat wobei sich auch das ändert also
große supermarktketten alle sind jetzt
dabei masken auch zu verkaufen haben ja
auch ein geschäft wäre aber nicht kaufen
will kann auch privat da finderin werden
herr baumann fragte ich leide an profit
ist und bekomme im normalen alltag schon
schlecht luft die maske erstickt mich
fast darf ich jetzt keine geschäfte mehr
betreten oder mit dem bus fahren
auch da muss man sagen die massen
pflicht gilt zwar wenn am ende jedes
bundesland sie umgesetzt hat
deutschlandweit es gibt aber keine
deutschlandweite masken pflicht deshalb
ist es immer ganz wichtig zu schauen wo
wohne ich und welche regeln gelten da wo
ich bin
es kann gut sein dass es in einzelnen
bundesländern und kommunen oder städten
vorgesehen dass es ausnahmen gibt zum
beispiel sehen einige bundesländer vor
dass kinder unter sechs jahren keine
masken tragen müssen weil man das gar
nicht hinkriegen kann oder dass menschen
mit einer erkrankung wie in diesem fall
keine masken tragen muss da muss man
sich natürlich ein nachweis besorgen das
im zweifel vorliegen oder belegen können
aber es kann ausnahmen von dieser masken
pflicht geben
die letzte frage von herrn krech warum
müssen wir auf die massen die uns
verordnet werden 19 prozent
mehrwertsteuer bezahlen statt 7 prozent
wie für andere lebenswichtige artikel ja
es eine berechtigte frage das natürlich
der regelsteuersatz natürlich könnte man
sagen jetzt wo jeder eine maske tragen
soll und man da vielleicht auch über
monate weiß über jahre investieren muss
könnte man ja sagen die sind so wichtig
dass wir den mehrwertsteuersatz senken
dass am ende aber eine politische
entscheidung keine juristische kann man
könnte es anders machen
dankeschön seiner attacke für diesen
überblick mehrere zehntausend schüler
haben am montag ihren ersten schultag
nach sechs wochen kroner zwangspause
gerade die abschlussklassen sollen jetzt
die gelegenheit haben sich auf ihre
anstehenden prüfungen vorzubereiten
viele eltern sehnen den tag herbei an
dem ihre kinder
endlich wieder in die schule gehen und
viele fragen sich wie wird der
schulalltag dann wohl aussehen
abstand halten heißt es dabei sind kaum
schüler da nichts ist normal an diesem
schultag in aachen
die zehntklässler starten hier heute
erstmal nur mit einzelgesprächen
der unterricht soll dann in kleinen
gruppen stattfinden
maximal zehn schüler und nur die
kernfächer schule und irgendwie doch
nicht
ich weiß nicht wie ich das finden soll
also das was mir an schule gefällt ist
es kommunizieren mit anderen und das
lernen und den austausch der austausch
aber das fällt jetzt irgendwie weg die
schule hat sich vorbereitet auf diesen
tag
es gibt neue sitz regeln in den
klassenräumen und anweisungen zur
richtigen treppen nutzung eine
gemeinschaftseinrichtung übt
vereinzelung bis hin zu den toiletten
es kann nur eine person jeweils auf
toilette gehen das heißt wir werden eine
kollegin oder einen kollegen so
platzieren mit einem
der genau erfasst welcher schüler geht
wann auch toiletten um infektionsketten
nach halten zu können jetzt
unterzeichnen erstmal die großen eine
individuelle hygiene vereinbarung zum
unterrichtsbeginn
sie beginnen mit einem siebtel der
schülerschaft das gehe gerade noch
alleine an der zahl wird jedem deutlich
wie groß die herausforderung sein wird
wenn zusätzliche jahrgänge an die
schulen kommen das geht bis zu einem
gewissen grad gut weil man ja auch zum
beispiel die abstände in den
klassenräumen einhalten muss aber
irgendwann kommen die gebäude auch an
ihre grenzen auch psychisch ist es eine
grenzsituation einige schüler schreiben
an diesem morgen in der mensa ihr vor
abitur ab mitte mai sollen die abi
prüfungen in nordrhein westfalen
stattfinden
dagegen regt sich heftiger widerstand im
netz und auf der straße die schule
boykott ihrer protestiere mit einer
genehmigten mini demonstration vor der
staatskanzlei
ich gehe heute nicht zur schule weil ich
ganz klar sage aus solidarität stehen
diejenigen die heute nicht zur schule
können
das heißt die leute die in risikogruppen
sind die leute die eng mit risikogruppen
zusammenleben
sie können heute auch nicht zur schule
und eben auch keine bessere
abiturvorbereitung wahrnehmen
den abiturienten an rhein und ruhr ist
es freigestellt am unterricht
teilzunehmen
die prüfungen selbst hingegen sind
verpflichtend masken sind übrigens nicht
verpflichtend in der schule aber
trotzdem gibt es sie
es ist eben ein besonderer schulstart
mit wenig schülern und viel protest
wir sollten soweit es geht persönliche
kontakte neigen damit die ansteckung
skore von corona nach unten geht gerade
für risikopatienten könnte es sonst
gefährlich werden damit die bewohner
eines behindertenheims in wuppertal
geschützt werden haben sich die pfleger
zu einem sehr ungewöhnlichen schritt
entschlossen
das corona virus trend viele menschen in
dieser einrichtung für behinderte in
wuppertal ist es jedoch genau
andersherum
ein großer teil der betreuer hat sich
nämlich hier eingerichtet verlässt das
heim also erst einmal nicht mehr so will
man die pflegebedürftigen vor ansteckung
schützen denn die gehören zur
risikogruppe erreichen möchten wir dass
die leute hier nicht infiziert werden
und der größte risikofaktor ist ja
eigentlich die hohe fluktuation gerade
im schichtwechsel in unserem bereich der
pflege und genau das haben wir jetzt
quasi eingedämmt und ich glaube schon
dass wir in der lage sind oder hier fern
zu halten
für die 21 bewohner ist es nicht einfach
nur ein virus sondern eine ganz konkrete
gefahr für ihr leben entsprechend freuen
sie sich dass diese gefahr nun
wenigstens minimiert wird
[Musik]
es ist eine freude die auf
gegenseitigkeit beruht denn für die
pfleger ist klar sie haben weniger einen
beruf sondern vielmehr eine berufung man
hat freunde man hat familie aber ich
krieg nur guten zuspruch von meiner
familie von meinen freunden und die
finden das klasse was wir hier machen
und am ende geht es darum dass man den
leuten hier was gutes tut und da kann
man sein eigenes privates leben auch mal
ein bisschen zurückschrauben man hat er
später immer noch zeit für also ich
fühle mich sehr gut dabei
das heim ist nun eine eigene welt
abgeschottet von der großen welt draußen
wo das corona virus kassiert aber alles
was gebraucht wird findet seinen weg in
das haus es ist so dass wir von externen
gut beliefert werden also menschen die
jetzt hier aufgrund persönlicher oder
gesundheitlicher gründe nicht mit in der
absonderung stärken die versorgung uns
quasi so gut dass wir bestens versorgt
sind hier wie lange die krone bedingte
wg von pflegepersonal und bedürftigen
noch andauern wird ist unklar
klar ist aber schon jetzt der neue
zusammenhalt wird darüber hinaus bleiben
sie haben uns viele fragen geschickt zum
thema masken pflicht bei uns ist jetzt
professor bruno platter von der
universitätsmedizin meinte hat die
antwort nicht grüße ganz herzlich
eine frage kommt von bernd kittelmann er
schreibt ich trage seit einiger zeit
beim einkaufen ein plexiglas visier das
von der stirn bis über das kinn reicht
und an den seiten von ohr zu ohr schützt
dieses visier darf ich dass statt einer
maske tragen das ist keine ideale maßen
kann die allermeisten das war man ja im
prinzip mit der maske versucht die
flüssigkeit aufzufangen
hierbei muss hier wird natürlich sage
ich dann unter umständen die luft schon
die tröpfchen nach außen getragen werden
unter umständen eben weiter verbreitet
werden also nicht wirklich ideal
sag mal steffen fragt bisher habe ich
gedacht dass man masken bei 60 grad
waschen soll eine apothekerin sagte
jetzt 30 grad und das einwirken in
seifenwasser würde reichen stimmt das ja
das sind so empfehlungen die immer
wieder jetzt kommen wenn man jetzt im
labor sehen würde sein würde dann würde
man tatsächlich 60 grad vorschreiben
feuchte hitze war nur dass eben sicher
auch diese erreger inaktiviert alles was
drunter ist kann wirken aber es ist halt
nicht zuverlässig eine frage von klaus
weber wie kann man so sicher sein dass
es schnell einen impfstoff geben wird
gegen das hi virus gibt es seit circa 35
jahren keinen impfstoff und wirksamer
medikamente waren erst nach zehn jahren
verfügbar
warum jetzt der optimismus bei corona
wir haben ganz so schnell was den
impfstoff natürlich auch nicht geben da
haben wir diese zeit ein nein ja
vielleicht oder so in der richtung und
hiv sind ganz andere erreger hiv ist ein
reger der das immunsystem tatsächlich
angreift der sehr variabel ist und der
immer wieder entkommt wenn man so möchte
so dass wir ganz andere situation haben
das erwartet mir eigentlich bei diesem
erreger zunächst mal nicht sondern wir
glauben eigentlich schon dass der durch
das immunsystem gut kontrolliert wird
carolina es fragt meine eltern benutzen
masten fassen sie beim auf- und absetzen
aber von beiden seiten an damit ist der
schutz doch hinfällig oder wieso immer
wieder sagen hände können nicht
infiziert werden über hände kann man
sich nicht infizieren kann sich
infiziert wird händen ins gesicht
gelangt
das heißt also ist macht nicht einmal
die maske von beiden seiten angepasst
was ich hinterher unmittelbaren
natürlich die hände wäscht oder wenn es
nicht anders geht und
desinfektionsmittel nimmt dann hat man
ist man natürlich auch auf der sicheren
seite aber die maske müsste dann
natürlich auch entsprechend sicher
verstaut dann noch eine frage von frau h
jedes kind soll in der grundschule
künftig eine maske aufsetzen sind diese
masten nicht schon nach einer
unterrichtsstunde feucht und
durchgeatmet also unbrauchbar kenntnis
dann ist es noch nicht so ganz
durchgängig in den bundesländern
tatsächlich geregelt man muss natürlich
gucken inwieweit das sich umsetzen das
natürlich sollten die nicht durch
feuchten mal gucken ob das funktioniert
aber natürlich geht auch da natürlich
wenn es irgendwie geht abstand halten
und die anderen hygieneregeln und da
wird man sehen ob das mit den masken
funktioniert bei den kleinen ab montag
alle masken pflicht haben wir sollten
die maske jeden abend dann waschen wenn
das möglich wäre natürlich ideal
zustand weil die natürlich irgendwann
durch berichtet und auch unangenehm wird
natürlich dann fragt frau beugt
angeblich ist das virus so klein dass
die selbst produzierten baumwolle masken
viel zu durchlässig sind nutzen die dann
überhaupt was zuletzt stimmt natürlich
viren sind sehr klein aber die wir uns
sind ja auf diesen tröpfchen das heißt
man möchte da nicht in die viren selber
eigentlich wegfangen sondern die
tröpfchen die maus atmet die dann eben
in diesem gewebe hängen bleiben und dann
tatsächlich auch eben quasi weg sind
wenn man so möchte die wir uns selber
würden durchgehen und das ist auch der
grund warum eben diese durchfeuchten
macht masken nicht mehr verwenden sollte
man dann natürlich die viren dann auch
auf der außenseite erscheinen
dann haben wir noch eine anonyme frage
bekommen ich habe gehört dass solche
masken enorme gesundheitliche probleme
verursachen können stichwort co2 im blut
und in der lunge
stimmt das aber bislang gibt es da
eigentlich keine hinweise darauf
natürlich wenn man höherwertige masten
verwendet wie im klinikalltag die sind
natürlich dichter aber diese mund
nasenschutz es sind ja nicht so dicht
dass man da wirklich der
atemschwierigkeiten bekommt wenn man die
schwierigkeit natürlich bekommt sollte
man natürlich dann unter umständen die
maske wegnehmen natürlich bevor man
umfeld sollte man auf jeden fall das
teil entfernt
das ganz klar professor brachte
herzlichen dank für diesen überblick
ja so viel zu unserem corona kompakt für
heute heute abend gibt es um 19 uhr 25
16 spezial mit norbert lehmann zum thema
corona krise im sport absagen pleiten
geisterspiele